l'aquitaine après l'aveyron a reçu
aujourd'hui la visite de monsieur
georges pompidou attendu ce matin à
l'aéroport de mérignac par monsieur
chaban delmas président de l'assemblée
nationale et maire de bordeaux et par
monsieur delaunay préfet gamme de la
région le premier ministre était
accompagné de monsieur olivier guichard
délégué général à l'aménagement du
territoire monsieur pompidou devait tout
d'abord survolé l'agglomération
bordelaise
il pouvait ainsi se rendre compte des
réalisations récentes et à venir
la zup le secteur de bordeaux nord
la cité du grand parc dont la population
atteindra 20 mille personnes lorsqu'elle
sera terminée et les travaux de
construction du troisième pont sur la
garonne
un pont suspendu long dans son ensemble
de trois kilomètres à la chambre de
commerce sur les questions de l'emploi
et de l'industrialisation
monsieur chaban delmas précisé dans la
répartition de cette industrialisation à
faire redémarrer pour les quatre ou cinq
années qui viennent pour retrouver
l'élan 60 à 64 nous efforcerons de
décentraliser cette industrialisation
je veux dire par là de ne pas nous en
tenir aux pôles bordeaux et au pôle
lâche d'ailleurs mais de jouer la chance
de certaines villes raleigh et monsieur
pompidou en conclusion de cette séance
de la colère à propos du problème
général le plus aigu des collectivités
locales celui de la recherche des
crédits déclarait qu'à l'heure actuelle
à la cadence actuelle l'épargnant france
s'accroît de 10% par an sur ce point
cinquième plan ne répond pas aux appels
que nous avons fait à l'occasion du
cinquième plan et il va le soin qu'il
est absolument nécessaire et français
fassent un effort des pannes accrue et
que cette cadence de 10 % soit dépasse
néanmoins comme nous espérons qu'elle le
sera comme par un peu de richesse
d'invention dans les formules d'appel
allez pas nous espérons arriver à
dépasser cette progression
nous avons en ce qui concerne le
financement pour l'année qui encourez
pour l'année prochaine
nous avons fait une étude approfondie de
façon à mettre les ressources à la
disposition des collectivités dans des
conditions convenables
d'ores et déjà les possibilités de prêts
la caisse des dépôts en 1966 par 1965 où
seront de l'ordre de 15 pour
ans de majoration par rapport à l'année
précédente et que par le jeu de la
caisse d'équipement nous avons créé et
de différents moyens nous sommes en
train de mettre au point avec monsieur
debré pour mettre à la disposition
d'actes de cette caisse des facilités de
trésorerie que dont elle peut disposer
vous arriveront finalement à eux qu'on
s'en tape de progression qu'on peut
fixer entre 20 et 25% en 1966 par
rapport 1965
je crois qu'il y aura là de quoi
satisfaire véritablement les besoins des
collectivités locales
de quoi répondre à tout ce qui dans ses
besoins est en tout cas urgents et
nécessaires
l'après-midi était consacré au survol de
la côte de la grande façade atlantique
qui restent à aménager
l'hélicoptère de monsieur pompidou se
posait d'arcachon où le premier ministre
pouvait constater l'avancement des
travaux d'assainissement du bassin et
l'aménagement du port de plaisance
monsieur pompidou serrer les mains des
arcachonnais venus le saluer
et après une visite au port il survolait
la côte vers capbreton et hossegor
là monsieur pompidou dans une courte
allocution à propos de l'aménagement du
port devait évoquer les problèmes du
tourisme et du développement de la
navigation de plaisance
la visite s'est terminée à biarritz où
le premier ministre a pris l'avion pour
paris ici biarritz jean marc est à vous
paris